for a year now many women including
friends and family members of mine
probably friends and family members of
yours too
have refused to get the covid vaccine
out of fear that it would disrupt their
menstrual cycle
the experts called these women idiots
conspiracy theorists anti-science rubes
the public health establishment spoke
with one voice through the largest media
channels in america to fact check and
debunk these claims the science we were
told was clear the covid vaccines do not
affect women's menstrual cycles
we're going to turn now to our dr jen
ashton who has some answers to some of
your more pressing medical questions
we'll start with the first one dr jen is
there a relationship between the
vaccines and menstrual cycles we've
definitely talked about we sure have you
guys and this is really spreading like
wildfire on social media with zero
scientific or medical basis for this
remember in medicine every time we talk
about a study of finding what is the
first thing we say big difference
between association
and causation so yes women can get the
vaccine and then experience changes in
their menstrual cycle that does not mean
that one causes the other and in fact if
you look at the biology of how these
vaccines work there is
zero hormonal interaction so please
let's put that to rest yes this got a
lot of attention because a school
actually in florida was telling teachers
yeah they used sight at this as a reason
for not being vaccinated defy science so
always good to repeat thank you can you
believe that a school was using this
kind of rumor this this thing spreading
like wildfire can we put it to rest
please okay there's no evidence
that the vaccines affect women's
menstrual cycles
it's not even possible for the vaccines
to affect women's menstrual cycles it
defies
science except whoopsie daisy turns out
the vaccines change women's menstrual
cycles
according to a new study
published on thursday
in the journal obstetrics and
gynecology just revealed that many women
vaccinated against covet 19 saw a delay
in the onset of their menstrual periods
compared to unvaccinated women
the national institutes of health
have now admitted the possibility that
the vaccines affect women's menstrual
cycles and the establishment media
including abc which ran that segment
that we just heard
are admitting it too here's the abc
headline
kovid19
vaccine linked to small temporary
changes in menstrual cycles study fines
you see
it's just a small change it's just a
temporary change
the public health experts and media
propagandists who told us for the better
part of a year that this vaccine side
effect was not only non-existent but
impossible
are now telling us not to worry when it
happens
if you still believe a word that comes
out of these people's mouths then i fear
you are suffering from a side effect not
of the vaccines but of the mass
psychosis that our rulers have inflicted
on society i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from keith shaw who
says the only comparison between
december 7th september 11th and january
6th
is the amount of news coverage that they
have received that's true
that's true despite kamala harris saying
that terrorists flying airplanes into
buildings and killing 3 000 americans is
the same thing very similar to a horn
hat guy dancing around the capital
rotunda those events have nothing to do
with one another except
the media coverage that they've gotten
and and if the media succeed at
mythologizing january 6th
they'll be thought of in much the same
way in american history that's a real
downside of our
propaganda machine that we have in this
country
now if you want some upside i would
recommend you check out get upside i'm
thrilled to introduce an incredible app
that everyone who buys gas needs to know
about
get upside my listeners right now are
making up to 25 cents for every gallon
of gas every time they fill up just by
downloading the free get upside app in
the app store or google play right now
and using promo code nulls actually
i should go a little further they're
making 25 cents for every gallon
except for those first gallons on your
first fill up you can actually get up to
50 cents cash back all right do not pay
full price of the pump anymore do not
leave cash on the table get cash back
using get upside it's super simple
download the app use promo code knowles
you get the cash back very easily
directly to your bank account or if you
prefer through an amazon gift card or
through paypal or a few other ways too
there's no catch whatever just cash back
download the get upside app right now
from google play or the app store use my
promo code knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
you will get back up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank that
is code nulls
i have no reason to believe
that
the relationship between the covid
vaccine and the menstrual cycle
is anything more than a small and
temporary change
it might very well be just according to
the study it only delayed women's period
by
15 hours 17 hours
so it might be a small change
the issue is
the experts
and the public health gurus and the
officials and the media
journalist communicators
told us that this could not happen
that it was not possible
that
not only was there no evidence for it
but it it defied the science which means
that these people the public health
experts the gurus the journalists
are either idiots they have no idea
what's going on they just don't know
what they're talking about in which case
we shouldn't believe a word they say or
they're liars
they know that there very likely is a
link but they think that it's better to
downplay it or to deny it altogether
because they don't want to discourage
people from getting the vaccine
they're a lot they're deceivers in which
case there's no reason to believe a word
they say or as i suspect is the case
they're both i think they're actually
idiots and liars
regardless
if you are still believing these people
the fouchies
and the met bringing on now our network
medical analyst is coming on to debunk
all these if you believe these people
i can't help you i i i i after two years
of this of them getting caught in error
after error and lie after willful
intentional lie after lie
i don't know how to help you then you're
lost you have been hypnotized
because
it's it's not just about this study or
that study it's not just about well do
the masks really protect against this
kind of particle or do they or did dr
fetch you really think they didn't work
or they really did work
well does the vaccine really change the
matter how much it's not about the
details it's about the fact that these
people either have no idea what they're
talking about or are lying to you or
both some people still don't get it
whoopi goldberg
host of the view
just got the rona and she couldn't
believe that she got the rona because
she did everything that the public
health experts told her to do
i left
a couple weeks ago just before the break
because
uh somebody i had been around
tested positive for coron virus so i
left so i've been gone a long time i
feel and
i was all excited and and uh you know
they have to test us and so they sent
people to test me
and uh
they tested me and it was like oh no
you're not you're not coming back
without sending anybody to your house
you have corona
and it was like wait what
what it was it was a shock because you
know i'm triple backstab i've been
anywhere i've done anything but that's
the that's the thing about the omicron
you just don't know where it is you
don't know where it is who's got it
who's passing it so you know it's one of
those things where you think i've done
everything i was supposed to do yeah it
doesn't it doesn't um it doesn't stop
omicron and that's the problem with a
variant because it gets stronger and
does different stuff to you so you know
unless everybody gets vaccinated this is
what we're going to be facing
for the next uh you know a little while
she's so close but she still doesn't get
it because did you hear what she said
she said look that's why we just all
need to get vaccinated because right now
what's happening is is the unvaccinated
or getting infected
and the unvaccinated are allowing the
virus to mutate and the unvaccinated or
transmitting the virus and so that's
what we just all need to we just need to
more closely follow what these idiots
are telling us to do and then there
won't be any more coronavirus except
except despite the fact that our rulers
and the public health experts told us
that the vaccines would stop us from
being infected and transmitting the
virus they then reversed course and they
admitted that the vaccines actually
don't prevent you from contracting or
transmitting the virus
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission you know we didn't have
vaccines that block transmission
we got vaccines to help you with your
health but they only slightly reduce the
transmissions we need a new
new way of doing the vaccine the level
of virus in the nasopharynx
of a person who's vaccinated and
infected
is the same level as the level of virus
in the nasal parents of an unvaccinated
person reports from our international
colleagues including israel
suggest increased risk of severe disease
amongst those vaccinated early
and if you look at israel
which is always been a month to a month
and a half
ahead of us they are seeing
a waning of immunity not only against
infection
but against hospitalizations
and to some extent death a booster might
actually be an essential part
of the primary regimen that people
should have everything we told you
before isn't true but do what we say now
that's what they're saying the
definition of insanity
is doing the same thing over and over
and over and over again and expecting a
different result
and that that's what whoopi goldberg
saying she's saying i did everything
they told me to do and they told me i
was going to be okay but then i wasn't
and i got the vacci and i got the
vaccine and i got the booster and i but
i still got kovit and i was around
people with the vaccines in the booster
and i still get it doesn't make sense oh
i guess i better just keep doing what
they tell me to do
i
it's so strange i was told that the
vaccines could not possibly change my
menstrual cycle but then they did
guess i better listen to the experts
more no
no i don't i don't think that's true i
think that if you have two brain cells
to rub together
i hate to be so harsh but if you have
two brain cells to rub together
you must conclude at this point
that whatever the experts tell you
about coved about the vaccines about the
masks about about what you should have
for breakfast in the morning is
not credible
they might be right but they'll only
accidentally be right they've squandered
all of their credibility it is as though
people
have been hypnotized
if one of my employees had as bad a
record as all these genius experts and
propagandists have
for the past two years i would fire them
and then i would need to go check out
zip recruiter 2022 is going to be a huge
year for a lot of businesses okay i
think it's going to be true for almost
all businesses but in particular certain
industries pet services is one that's
projected to explode
fitness digital events and conferences
home improvement if you work for or own
a business in one of those growing
industries or a wide range of other
industries you probably need to hire
asap there's only one way to do it zip
recruiter right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles sip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review the
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster you're
not just throwing spaghetti at the wall
you're actually going out there finding
the top candidates inviting them to
apply no wonder
ziprecruiter is the number one job
recruitment tool in the u.s based on g2
ratings zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate in the first day right
now try it for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com knowles
that's ziprecruiter.comcnwlis
ziprecruiter the smartest way to hire it
feels as though we are living in a mass
psychosis when you when you walk up to a
friend of yours or a family member and
they've got three masks on and they've
taken 57 jabs and they tell you they've
done everything dr fauci told them to do
and then they're still getting the virus
and they're still transmitting it and
they can't make sense of it and they
don't understand it but they just keep
doing what fauci tells them to do it
seems as though
a man with a long pocket watch must have
hypnotized them and that is what dr
robert malone who is one of the pioneers
of the mrna vaccines though he's now
become a big skeptic
of the coveted response and of those
vaccines he went on joe rogan's show
and he said we are living in a sort of
mass psychosis
what the heck happened in germany
in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad
and how did that happen
um
the answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has
free-floating anxiety in a sense that
things don't make sense
we can't understand it and then their
attention gets focused by a leader or
series of events on one small point just
like hypnosis
they
literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere
and one of the aspects of that phenomena
is the people that they identify as
their leaders the ones typically that
come in and say you have this pain and i
can solve it for you i and i alone
okay can fix this problem for you
okay then they will lead they will
follow that person through it doesn't
matter whether they lie to them or
whatever the data are irrelevant
and furthermore anybody who questions
that narrative is to be immediately
attacked they are the other
so what robert malone is describing here
is he's saying it seems like people have
gone crazy it seems like the people
who are still following the rulers and
the leaders who have gotten everything
wrong the fact that they're still
following them seems crazy and the fact
that they're wearing all these masks and
taking all these jabs and cowering in
fear from the cough really seems kind of
crazy doesn't it when he uses this
phrase mass formation psychosis it's
just a
strange unusual way of saying it seems
like our whole society's gone nuts
and we're all under the spell of a
ruling class
that
peddles its propaganda
constantly
so in response to this
the ruling class and their propagandists
issued a fact checked and they said
reuters reuters fact check there is no
evidence to suggest a mass formation
psychosis has occurred during the
pandemic experts told reuters
oh yeah that's going to convince me that
that didn't happen yeah the fact that
the hypnotists are denying it yeah
that'll totally convince me
do what you're getting very very sleepy
yeah you're getting sleepy sheep and you
need to give me all of your rights and
your way of life hey i think that guy's
hypnotizing us no
no i'm not
uh dr fauci is totally not hypnotizing
you
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain that's not
whether it's it's true or not that is
not going to be persuasive
when the people that you accuse of doing
something wrong
deny it and don't provide any evidence
as to how they're not doing that it does
it does seem to me that the people who
have led us who have been exposed
repeatedly
as
not knowing what they're talking about
or deceiving us
that
maybe they're doing something wrong
and maybe that the fact that we continue
to follow them
is a sign that we're not totally in our
right minds fact checks
are the cheapest form of propaganda out
there
because what a what a fact check is it
was this phenomenon that really only
became popular maybe 10 or so years ago
it was a way for left-wing news outlets
to turn left-wing opinion columns
into
an unassailable
news story so many of these fact checks
are simply
presenting a left-wing perspective on on
certain facts but they say this is a
fact you five pinocchios this is a fact
mostly true mostly false pants on fire
and because it's a fact you're not
you're not permitted to disagree with it
the right wing opinion here is that
people have lost their minds that people
have gone crazy by following dr fauci
that it does that it's not rational to
follow dr fauci and then the left comes
out and they say no it is rational fact
check
seven pinocchios so
i'll give you an example of a really
egregious fact check
reuters again came out
and
they are focusing on vaccine adverse
events the side effects the vaccine
injuries of which there are many
since 1990 the u.s vaccine adverse event
reporting system vares has provided data
on any adverse reactions that have been
reported following a vaccination anyone
can submit a report which gives the
system transparency but is also a
limitation
you see what the fact check is though
you know you might be seeing a lot of
events reported in vares
the vaccine injury system you got to
remember these aren't verified vaccine
injuries okay anyone can submit a report
so there's a lot of problems here you
probably shouldn't believe
all those vaccine injuries you see in
vares okay
so from that quote unquote fact check
you would infer
that vaccine injuries are over reported
in the vaccine adverse event reporting
system
right they're saying it's not verified
so presumably a lot of these are just
not real ignore them forget about it
except
that not only are vaccine injuries not
over reported in vares they're
significantly underreported they're
under reported by 99
actually there's a 2010 hhs review that
came out of the
vares system the vaccine adverse event
reporting system showed quote
adverse events from drugs and vaccines
are common but under reported although
25 of ambulatory patients experience an
adverse drug event less than 0.3 of all
adverse drug events and 1 to 13 percent
of serious events are reported to the
fda likewise here's the money line
likewise fewer than 1
of vaccine adverse events are reported
this is from the department of health
and human services you can get this on
the government website right now
less than one percent
so if you just read the fact check
you would you would conclude
the opposite of the facts
the fact is that there are a lot of
vaccine injuries and they are
drastically underreported almost none of
them are reported
relative to the total number of vaccine
injuries
but wait a second i thought we were told
by the propagandists that vaccine
injuries
if either never happen or barely ever
happen or look the other way or don't
look at the man behind the curtain
incredibly dishonest stuff you're not
just getting it out of reuters and the
propagandists you're getting it
from the supreme court sonia sotomayor
the self-styled
wise latina woman on the supreme court
that's how she pitched herself to join
the court
she was hearing oral arguments over the
biden administration's vaccine mandate
and she
pulled a fact of of covet
hospitalizations
out of thin air
we have hospitals that are almost at
full capacity with people is severely
ill on ventilators we have over a
hundred thousand children
which we've never had before in in
serious condition
and
many on ventilators
hundred thousand children in very
serious condition hospitalized many of
that hundred thousand on ventilators
that's just completely made up
there are right now and this is the most
wild outlandish generous liberal
estimate
there were fewer than 3 500 pediatric
hospitalizations from kovid
how many of those are really serious
totally unclear because a lot of people
are pretty trigger happy now if they get
the cough they'll run to the hospital
fewer than 3 500 hospitalizations
very different than a hundred thousand
i'm beginning to conclude
that justice sotomayor may not be the
wisest latina woman out there
i'm beginning to but
she went to very fancy schools i think
she went to yale law school she's on the
supreme court and she
seems to believe this stuff
if a united states supreme court justice
believes
a completely outlandish delusion
about the scope of the coronavirus
epidemic
i suspect a lot of other people do too
i suspect
that the fantasy
is driving our discourse much more than
the facts
and i suspect that we are living our
lives and ordering our society and
making our laws and rules
much more based on fantasy
than on fact
i think if people knew the facts
about
the risk to children we would have
reopened the schools
much much sooner i think if people knew
the facts about the coveted risk to
relatively young relatively healthy
people we would have gone back to work a
long long time ago
i just had code that i just recovered
about a week ago it wasn't pleasant but
it's fine my whole family had it wasn't
pleasant it's fine people get sick
that's what happens
i think if if women knew the facts about
the now
accepted reality that the vaccines can
alter a woman's menstrual cycle at least
somewhat then maybe they would be more
reluctant to get it or they would they
would have some justification for
refusing to get it if people knew the
facts about the moral compromise
involved in creating the vaccines if
people knew the risk if people knew the
realities here and if people knew that
the
public health experts quote unquote and
the officials and their propagandists in
the media if they knew that they were
freaking lying to us
and just getting stuff wrong constantly
from the very beginning
they might look on this
biomedical terror regime with a little
more skepticism
but
the liberal establishment has done a
basically a pretty good job
at controlling
the narrative
with fact check after fact checked after
fact check that if you contradict it you
could be ostracized censored kicked out
of society and no one will hear from you
again
you know when everyone else was kneeling
some men had the courage to stand alone
one of those men is nba star jonathan
isaac who despite facing heavy criticism
from the media for his views on social
issues and vaccines over the past few
years still stood strong which is why
i'm extraordinarily excited to announce
that he has decided to write a book with
the daily wire called why i stamped
jonathan's book will be about the rise
of his basketball career his journey
into faith and his strength to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
check out this teaser
the orlando magic's 23 year old starting
forward is deeply religious and proudly
unvaccinated on friday isaac got
attention for choosing not to kneel in
unison with his teammates or to wear a
black lives matter shirt my name is
jonathan isaac i play for the orlando
magic
and i'm writing a book with the daily
wire
[Music]
courage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes in
[Music]
i can't wait it looks terrific
jonathan is a great guy and i love that
he had the guts to stand firm so his
book will be one of the first under
daily wires new publishing arm dw books
we could not be happier to have him on
board the book is available for
pre-order now at amazon so reserve your
copy today we will be right back with a
lot more
if you believe
what justice soda sonia sotomayor said
during oral arguments on the vaccine
mandate case if you believe that there
are a hundred thousand kids right now on
death's door in the hospital from kovid
you would probably be pretty freaked out
the fact that there aren't that she
completely made that up
is beside the point if that were true
you would probably be pretty
scared
which brings up the
craziest tweet thread i think i've i've
ever read
this was a
a tweet thread from bob wachter
bob wachter has a 28 year old son
who got kovid
he writes quote
i've been tweeting about kovid for
nearly two years but this week it became
personal when my 28 year old younger son
got it
with his permission i'll describe his
experience and how i approach the
situation given the realities of life
and the rapidly changing evidence my son
who lives in san francisco is generally
healthy but overweight placing him in a
moderately high risk group
real nice to call your son fat in public
whatever he's been quite careful since
march 2020 and has received three
modernas
he used to wear a two-ply cloth mask
since ami i guess that's the nickname
for omikron he switched to a can 95 with
my encouragement in quotes
he works in downtown san francisco in
customer service so he has a lot of
people contact
i've worried that he'd get it from work
or from the bus but that's not how it
happened instead one of the few friends
he sometimes sees in person another
fully vast young person who has also
been quite careful came over monday
night to watch a movie she felt fine as
did he
wednesday am 36 hours later he woke up
and felt awful sore throat dry cough
muscle aches chills no taste or smell
abnormalities i told him to stay home
drink fluids and take tylenol or advil
local pharmacies were all out of rapid
tests but i had one stashed away he came
outside i wore an n95 and we ran it with
a nasal swab it was negative i was a
little reassured though was he was not
dad it just feels like i felt after my
vaccine he said
he seemed sick enough to be infectious i
wondered if he'd be an example of the
newly reported problems with false
negative rapid tests in the first days
of an omicron infection he called the uc
san francisco hospital's covet hotline
he's a patient to get a pcr or a color
piece
this is
we're now six tweets in
we're six streets and talks about the
tests that he got
says the next day i called him at 9am no
answer my brain knows the odds of a
fully vast young person dying or near
zero still i wondered briefly if he'd
survived the night survive the night
because he had a cough
survived the night because he had the
symptoms of a cold
goes on and on and on and on
we now get to the
the 24th tweet
in this thread
should he have watched movies with his
friend i think so it seemed like a
fairly safe encounter but while ami is
surging even low-risk stuff things that
were safe last month may now be risky
given how quickly this storm may pass it
seems wise to hunker down a bit just a
bit just a few more years just hunker
down a few more years my son should be
okay but the illness and the anxiety it
causes are miserable resigning ourselves
to getting omicron doesn't seem right
especially since the surge may be
short-lived i still think it's an
experience best avoided for you and your
loved ones if you can so i got to the
end i got to the end i read the whole
thing
i thought i hope his son doesn't die it
must be that's the only reason you're
right at 25. no his son is just fine his
son got the equivalent of a cold
his 28 year old son
and is fine that's the point i could
have done that in two sentences
he did it in 25 tweets
this is not just some random kook that
wouldn't be news
if it were some random kook neurotic
writing this 25 tweet thread
this man is the chairman of the medicine
department at uc san francisco
this this man is one of the experts
he's one of the gurus leading us through
this epidemic and he has clearly lost
his marbles he is out of his mind
absolutely ravaged by fear and neurosis
i am older than this man's son
by a few years
i have been smoking cigars since i was
15. i have not exercised since the obama
administration
when i got kovid
i didn't really tell anyone
i think i took a couple advil ones
i changed
absolutely nothing about my behavior or
life
and now i feel just fine
that should i hope that's reassuring
this man is saying that we shouldn't
watch movies with our friends just a few
more years to slow the spread
this is the evidence of the mass
psychosis remember when reuters said
there's no there's no evidence of mass
sight no evidence of hypnotism this is
the evidence this is a psychosis
we need to stop this so how do you stop
it
because
as anyone who's ever gotten to a into an
argument with his wife can attest saying
calm down is not an effective strategy
to get someone to calm down saying well
how do i stop being so nervous well just
don't be nervous well easier said than
done so how do you do it how do you get
society to stop being so
neurotic and terrified and on a hair
trigger all the time
this is going to sound a little
unorthodox
we need to stop testing for coronavirus
we just need to stop testing
we are all taking way too well not all i
almost never take a test for chronovirus
but
only when i absolutely am forced to it
basically at gunpoint will i do it but a
lot of people are taking a lot of tests
for the coronavirus stop it you should
stop doing it the consensus view as you
heard from washington post's paul kane
on cnn
is that we we just need more tests in
america he's actually criticizing joe
biden because biden is not sending out
enough tests
which is it right now that is the
biggest problem uh given the omicron
surge and what we're looking at right
now
uh it's the worst kind of problem they
have a policy problem and a messaging
problem uh the the policy side is
they went with a
vaccine only approach uh practically not
not entirely but very close they thought
they could vaccinate their way out of
this problem and phil how many times in
2020 when you were back up on the hill
how many times did nancy pelosi start
press conferences by saying testing
testing testing
every single time every single time she
said testing testing testing and this
administration with all the money in the
world from the bipartisan deals of 2020
and the unilateral democratic uh 1.9
trillion dollar bill in march they had
all the money in the world for testing
and they just didn't focus on it and
that was a huge mistake it's a huge
mistake they were always going to need
testing to get out of the school issue
and now the messaging in terms of what
comes out of the cdc
is just as confusing as it ever was
captioning
not
[Music]
i available of palucaville
i say go back to school
shut up teacher unions
go back to school you'll be fine
people have gone to school during flus
during colds during
epidemics
it's fine just go back to school and
shut your mouths
that's how you do it
but no you need the testing why do you
need the testing
on the contrary testing will not allow
us to get back to normal it will stop us
from ever getting back to normal because
when you test
when you test everyone in the country
all the time
for a mild illness
you're going to get some positive
results
and when everyone is constantly
on a hair trigger
about locking down and and
and terrified deathly terrified of this
virus then every time you get a positive
test you're going to shut down the
schools again this is what's happening
for my friends and relatives they send
their kids to these schools or
preschools
and then one kid tests positive and they
shut this place down for a week but if
you test everyone all the time
for an extraordinarily contagious virus
that isn't really that dangerous to
the vast vast vast majority of people
you're always going to get a positive
test and you're always going to lock
down the reason that the liberal
establishment
is now clamoring for more tests is
because they don't want the epidemic to
go away
they always want these emergency powers
they always want to be able to rule you
with whim and caprice and they never
want you to question what they're saying
even when what they're saying is
contradicting what they said the day
before this is a power play this has
been a power play from day one they've
done everything they can
in terms of the vaccines they've done
everything that they said was going to
work in terms of locking down and making
everyone wear masks and that didn't
really work they haven't done everything
they can in terms of getting
therapeutics out there they've actually
suppressed a number of therapeutics that
that would have helped
some people to recover from the virus
more quickly
they have said no forget about that
because they've taken as that washington
post correspondent says a vaccine-only
approach and they didn't want
therapeutics to get into the way of the
narrative that everyone needs to take
the vaccine
so that was one big mistake but they've
done what they are going to do
and just testing everyone and freaking
everyone out all the time over what is
effectively for the vast majority of
people a mild cold is only going to
prolong this do you know who gets this
maybe one man in america
who is in elected office gets this that
would be
ron desantis down in florida who says
we've got to stop the testing
now think about it before kovid did
anyone go out and seek testing to
determine if they were sick it's usually
you feel like you're sick and then you
get tested to determine what your what
you maybe have come down with and so
this is kind of a new thing where
they've been saying just go out and test
all the time and
again you're free to do it but i think
what what the the doh guidance from
florida is saying is that is unlikely to
yield very much clinical value for you
and it also creates a lot of pro second
order follow-up problems it's
essentially a lock down by stealth in
the sense of if you test positive but
you're not sick or have symptoms you may
have to isolate they don't even know the
test can't tell you if you're even
infectious or not and these pcr tests
you can test positive for weeks after
you've been infected months even in some
cases and so what happens is
blanket testing of healthy people it
leads to some kids being not not in
school at least to people not being able
to go to work and some doing some of
these isolation which is may not even be
justified
absolutely right 100 this guy gets it
this guy gets it all that more testing
is going to lead to is more lockdowns
when did we start taking tests to find
out if we were going to get sick now
what the libs are saying in response is
you idiot ron desantis what about cancer
screenings
because ron desantis wife is is
struggling with cancer and she's
fighting against cancer right now
they're saying you idiot you rube you
don't even know that people get
cancer screenings to to make sure that
that they they aren't sick
that's true
for certain
very very deadly illnesses
we will every year or two years or five
years or ten years get certain tests
done
to make sure that everything's looking
good because in some cases an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
we don't do that for the flu
we don't do that for the common cold
we shouldn't do that for covid
which
let's say is stronger and more dangerous
than the flu to some degree
i don't think we would do that for
double flu super flu
super duper mecha cold we wouldn't we
wouldn't do that sort of thing
you you wait until you get sick if if
there were 100 000 kids right now dying
on ventilators in hospitals from kovad
that would be a different story if the
narrative we were told about kovid by
the public health experts were true that
might be a different story but it's not
it's been proven wrong time and time
again
and so when you look at what the facts
actually are you should calibrate your
policy to the facts and that's very
inconvenient for the liberal
establishment which is trying to use
this cough to completely reorder society
and to a large degree has succeeded at
doing that
speaking of reordering society
i'm sure everyone was glued to their
screens this weekend watching the sports
event of the year the hotly contested
women's ivy league 100 meter race
right of course we know we watch that we
set our alarms we say how and this is
very important now especially because
it's a matter of social justice because
now in women's college sports men are
competing men who say that they're women
so that they can set new records and
break new ground for men taking stuff
from women okay the headline from the
women's ivy league 100 meter race
is that
the yale
transgender swimmer
beat the fee beat the pen transgender
swimmer
in the women's
competition
[Music]
hooray for justice now when most people
read this
they assumed it was a dude who's
pretending to be a woman beat another
dude who's pretending to be a woman at
the women's sport and this just shows
you how awful it is and transgenderism's
destroying women's sports but there's a
twist to this story which is that the
yale transgender swimmer is a
woman who wants to become a man but she
allegedly hasn't started taking hormones
or chemicals yet so she's still allowed
to compete on the women's team and the
pen transgender swimmer is a man who is
pretending to be a woman
but he's obviously physically much
bigger and stronger than all the other
women so he keeps winning all the races
but he
lost to the girl who's pretending to be
a man
this actually throws a wrench into the
transgenderism narrative of a lot of
people on the right
but it doesn't throw a wrench into my
theory on transgenderism i can't believe
it this we talked about this i think on
the very last episode of the show on
friday thursday or friday of last week
i mentioned
that and i've said this before as well
that
it's a mistake for conservatives to
stake their argument against
transgenderism on
fairness in women's sports or some other
disingenuous point that no one really
cares about
no i don't really care who gets the
medal at the women's track meet that's
not what's what's wrong with
transgenderism is is not that it takes
some accolades away from 11th grade
girls
what's wrong with transgenderism is that
it contradicts reality
if
if you stake your argument against
transgenderism on
women not being able to compete in
women's sports anymore then this story
about the yale
trans swimmer beating the pen trans
swimmer completely destroys your
argument
because in this case the woman beat the
man
and you know that's going to happen
sometimes i don't really know the
details here it's being reported that
the woman is not on any steroids it's
being reported that the man tried his
hardest and he didn't he didn't throw
the race and i don't know but maybe
maybe one in a million
the the woman beats the man it could be
the case so then
that's not a that's not a big deal okay
good that's fine then the men then the
men can compete in women's sports and
the women have a fighting chance
if fairness in women's sports is the
standard conservatives just lost if
reality is the standard conservatives
still have an argument
when we stake our arguments on
statistics we're going to lose because
there are lies damned lies and
statistics when when
rhonda sanchez was talking about this
too
if you're staking your argument as to
why we shouldn't completely reorder
society and take away all of people's
rights and close all the churches and
shut down business and have a massive
transfer of wealth largest in human
history from the poorer classes to the
upper classes if you're basing that on
testing statistics or even
hospitalization statistics
you're going to lose because everyone's
got their own statistics
if you base it on justice you're gonna
have a much better argument
it is unjust to take away all people's
rights and give it all to dr fauci the
schmuck who lies out of both sides of
his mouth every single day that would be
unjust regardless of the statistics then
you've got a strong it's unjust it's
just simply wrong
for men
to pretend to be women
in our society
it's just not right
they're not women and we shouldn't
indulge delusion and the truth will set
you free if you make that argument
then transgenderism is still
preposterous but if you try to make the
squishy
we're all individuals kind of
libertarian you do you i'll do me but
don't infringe on my right to win the
trophy if you make that argument
you're not going to win
the the yale trans swimmer just
destroyed your argument speaking of
weird sex
stuff britney spears
is celebrating her release from her
conservatorship
the hashtag free britney campaign
by tweeting out a fully nude photo of
herself or i suppose posting it to
instagram
the caption reads quote free woman
energy has never felt better
and i'm beginning to think maybe this
free britney campaign was not such a
great idea after
all 12 year old michael
i'm sure is furious right now with
31 year old michael for complaining
about a naked photo of britney spears
that's probably that's probably true but
i have to complain about it because this
is not a great idea
it actually does undermine the free
britney argument because this is pretty
strange
wacky self-destructive behavior now
britney spears is a pop star and pop
stars do these sorts of things so it's
not completely out of the ordinary but
the purpose of a conservatorship
is to put some constraints on people's
autonomy and individual choices because
they are not capable of handling their
freedom right maybe it's because you've
got some mental problem maybe it's
because you've got a drug problem
but
the idea behind a conservatorship is not
to take away your freedom but actually
to protect your freedom from your own
basis desires and your own basis
inclinations which will
destroy your freedom
it gets down to this argument that we're
having on the right right now about what
freedom really is
and the libertarians are saying that
i i'm painting with something of a broad
brush but generally the libertarians are
saying freedom is the ability to do
whatever you want whenever you want to
do it if i want to do drugs and and
sleep around and have all sorts of
self-destructive behaviors that's my
freedom
and the conservatives are saying no
freedom isn't the ability to just do
whatever you want whenever you want to
do it
freedom is the right to do what you
ought to do
so for the libertarian point of view the
modern liberal point of view
freedom is the heroin addict shooting up
heroin but the conservative knows that
the heroin addict is not free he's
actually a slave to his own basis
desires
if
if a society
treats its freedom as an excuse to just
get naked
and
dance around and
do a bunch of drugs and sleep around and
abuse liberty to licentiousness in the
words of our founding fathers then we're
not going to stay free for very long
that that kind of people is not capable
of freedom and so some guardrails are
going to have to be put on their
individual choice
and that's what you're seeing happen in
your government i don't really care that
much about the britney spears story in
and of itself but i care about the
political
significance of it
what we have done
as a people in recent decades
is
strip naked and post a bunch of pictures
of ourselves on instagram literally in
many cases but figuratively
as well
we have abused our freedom to
licentiousness we've proven ourselves
incapable of freedom in many instances
we can't even really conduct elections
anymore
no one trusts the result of our national
elections anymore democrats didn't trust
2016 republicans don't trust 2020.
democrats don't trust two thousand
we can't we we've torched our cities
over the past
year
and by we i mean leftists have torched
the cities over the past year we don't
we don't we can't defend our national
borders we can't educate ourselves we're
not and so what's going to happen
inevitably
is someone is going to impose order from
without if we are not capable of freedom
then someone else is going to impose
order from
outside that's
the way
it goes here
before we go i need to get to one point
from justice neil gorsuch
because this is to talk about fake news
going around about covet justice gorsuch
was hearing the oral arguments in the
case over the biden vaccine mandate
gorsuch said that every year a lot of
people die from the flu this was
misreported as gorsuch saying that every
year hundreds of thousands of people die
from the flu
flu kills
i believe hundreds of thousands of
people every year so this was reported
as him saying flu kills hundreds of
thousands of people a year but what you
heard right there it was a transcription
error what he said was it kills hundreds
thousands of people a year
now
that's true in the united states in the
united states flu kills tens of
thousands of people a year and they were
all the fact checkers saying gorsuch got
this wrong it's actually only tens of
thousands of people but worldwide flu
does kill hundreds of thousands of
people every year and it's a lesson for
all of us okay
he did he didn't say that but if you
look at flu worldwide even the the thing
that the fact checkers were debunking
actually is true
and it puts a lot in perspective here
folks we used to live with illness we
used to live with risk we used to live
with some degree of personal
responsibility and now we're not willing
to do that we're all cowering in the
corner and writing 25 tweet threads
about how scared we are of getting the
cough that kind of a people is not going
to be capable of freedom and the way of
life that we once cherished so which is
it which way american man i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
today on the ben shapiro show appointed
to the supreme court as a wise latina
justice sonia sotomayor proves herself a
fool that's today on the bench bureau
show give it a listen